do my intro do my show but then i'll say
now ladies and gentlemen for your
entertainment
this is the man that inspired howie
mandel to go in the show business his
uncle nate and then they played
joy
right you didn't enjoy yourself the
audience was really warmed up they
laughed at your first utterance no yeah
but they would anyway
[Music]
then i do i'm in vegas at the tropicana
monday tuesday wednesdays check the
dates anyway every monday tuesday
wednesday well not no not every monday
tuesday wednesday but a lot at the
tropicana the laugh factory which i'm
i'm going to be there grateful no you
wouldn't you were all right you were
already there you are we're already
there for god and i say you're fantastic
thank you he is fantastic i know i
appreciate that well you're there a lot
uh well yeah about
two three times a month sometimes once a
month
so anyway
so so
so anyway i just go out i go they go
here john i just go out by my so i don't
want i don't need
i don't need to warm up the crowd you
see i come out i'm so
[ __ ] hot
and as soon as i come out they're
boiling
and what time is the show and then
sometimes they're hot because they don't
turn the air conditioning on until
vegas and it's a desert
what time is the show
it's
it's the best time to have a show and
like it's seven o'clock because let me
tell you there's a seven o'clock show
it's in vegas there's a lot of stuff
going on at seven o'clock in las vegas
it sounds early
circus circus there's a monkey from that
sullivan show spinning plates right and
then there's uh
me a lot of people okay but it's a lot
of competition and then i go out and the
audience is like half full
right and i go they tell me it's sell
out and i can see all these empty seats
look at that [ __ ] monkey
draws
the rest of my crowd [ __ ] monkey all
right that's terrible do you get there
right at seven no obviously seven
o'clock monday tuesday wednesday it's
one of the worst times you could do a
show good promote promo but that's a
good promo but i but i don't have any
competition except for the monkey
and
and i um
enjoy it and usually the people that
come to the show they've eaten dinner at
four
you're really selling this
no but it's a good show and then and
then you know that's what they have
available and it's good practice for me
you know that's why that's it's a big
reason that i was good at your show
because i get to do all these extra
shows you know
[Music]